[Musique]
on entende continue je me rappelle du
visage de ma mère c'est j'ai vu la
panique dans son visage
déjà bien camouflage les armes à feu ou
et certains restaient comme c'était
comme regarder un film de guerre avec
nous mon frère c'est comme ex temps pour
nous de voir ça ça s'est fait en
quelques minutes après le décès du
caporal lemay quelques minutes à prix la
barka de terry géants de la cote c'est
une chaîne mon nom était en isère après
que j'avais 9 ans en 1990 durant la
crise d'oka jérémy tomlinson de sur nos
cours en parle avec émotion de cette
crise qu'il a vécu du côté mourad de la
barricade
il se rappelle intensément du premier
passage obligé au point de contrôle de
la police il était très directe car a
marre de faire sortir tous des occupants
du véhicule va avoir protesté un pizza
c'est mon petit grillage 1h20 puis le
poissy et avenues alentours du véhicule
il m'avait comme pointé son arme à feu
comme à un jeune de novarama rappelle
d'ailleurs le petit gars aux autochtones
issus de mariages mixtes étaient plutôt
excité par toute cette agitation est
fier de la démonstration de résistance
de son peuple il a déchanté quand est
venu le temps de retourner à son école à
la fin de l'été dans le village d'oka
quand je reçois des commentaires
racistes quand mais se fait appeler un
sauvage accepté rock tout est comme ça
vient d'où sauter comme tu comprends pas
c'est que c'est mauvais tu sais que tu
en es sûr parce que tu perds soi mais sa
vie est douce
vive le racisme encore trente ans plus
tard où ce cas notre territoire est au
jour en question tout le temps sans
dents pourquoi ça m'arrive c'est comme
pour qu'on doit tout le temps se battre
fact et comme en mode tout le temps
combes
tu m'appelles sonia ben duffy de bois
long et j'avais dix ans lors de la
résistance de canada guerre 1990 la vie
de sonia bones pilbois loup a elle aussi
était bouleversée à l'été 1990 héritière
de deux cultures par ses parents elle
vivait du côté non autochtone de la
barricade dans le village d'oka c'est
ici que je vivais en 1990
donc c'est là que vous étiez le 11
juillet oui cgt dans cette maison là
avec ma maman frère quand on a entendu
les coups de feu qui venait juste de
l'eau en fait parce que si on monte la
russie ça mène à la communauté il ya des
amis avec qui j'avais plus droit de
jouer il y avait des voisins qui nous
parlaient plus il y avait un regard
différent dans l'est dans les commerces
c'est un commerce qui a une pancarte de
crillon sert politisés ou pas d'un
indien quant à 10 ans de fait les voyons
mais que ça soit bon boulot est devenu
cinéaste
elle raconte dans un de ses films les
effets à court et long terme que cette
histoire a eu sur sa vie moi j'ai décidé
d'aller dans les médias puis de faire
des films de travailler sur des projets
qui rehaussait les cultures attaque
tonnes rappelle pascal que bio en 1990
lors de la crise donc j'avais 16
vous êtes né ici oui de quatrième
génération
mon père habite dans la maison de mon
arrière-grand-père encore j'ai une photo
de mes grands parents avec mes arrière
grands pères devant le presbytère des
subtiles pascal qui vit on vit toujours
à oka il a régulièrement côtoyé des
autochtones certains font même partie de
sa famille mais cet été de 1986 a changé
beaucoup de choses pour lui une certaine
cooper depuis 90 mais comme un lien de
confiance est brisé malheureusement
pascal quévillon est aujourd'hui le
maire d'oka il vit encore régulièrement
des regains de tensions avec certains
autochtones à propos de leurs
revendications territoriales
on marche on ne veut à chaque jour on
sait jamais ce qui peut arriver demain
matin on peut se lever et puis une
petite crise lucky qui se forment
[Musique]
les grands mouvements vont dans le bon
sens si on regarde les alors no more on
regarde les mémos niveau de la
commission vérité-réconciliation les
gens embarquent plus haut niveau
national
mais si on ramène l'entonnoir à la
racine de ce que déclencher toutes
seules un merci 90 c'est bien qu'ils
bougent et j'ai réglé après trouve au
sein
on est bien ancré ici là aussi l'eau
donc faut trouver un compromis pour que
tout le monde soit content sésame ça je
laisse pas je souhaite mais je crois
plus au père noël
du côté traditionnel j'ai le meilleur
ceci qu'on a que nous rappelle au
monastère jérémy tomlinson s'emploie
aujourd'hui à renouer avec ses racines
de morts qu il apprend la langue et les
coutumes traditionnelles et les transmet
aux enfants de l'école primaire de
calais s'attaquer son continue à ignorer
les faits ça partira jamais puis comme
n'importe quoi dans la vie
à quel moment qu'on peut dire savoir
éclaté de nouveau
on n'est plus dans l'aude quand ça va
arriver que six à avoir vu jean minot
arrêté
les enfants de la crise d'oka ont
aujourd'hui des enfants à qui
transmettent avec passion l'héritage
indélébile de cette crise de 1990 et des
précédentes
[Musique]